so you're here as part of the you know
and door
um and so um what are the chances that
your character survived and it's going
to be in Andor season two well put it
this way Tony Gilroy uh
uh said to me
he's still alive
that's what he said to me right so so
that means to me like they're somewhere
along the line some way
is a possibility that you might you
might be alive being like being serious
though it's very like Star Wars fans are
are let me be honest they're hyper
critical they pick apart everything but
your performance on Endor is something
that is universally praised people love
I love your performance everything I see
online people love your performance so
does that actually
um does that like change things in terms
of like you know anyone at lucasfilm all
of a sudden spitballing ideas on what
could happen yeah yeah absolutely of
course I mean if if a character becomes
popular sure sure there's a possibility
for for a future life yeah I mean I I
I seriously hope that this is going to
manifest because I really do I love the
character and I love playing that
character so much he's so he he's so
complex and flawed and human and brave
and and you know it was
I really love the Arc of the character
such as well and I think there's
definitely
you know I'm just imagining you're
sitting in Nikita five at the moment on
his own
practicing his backstroke you know but
what's really amazing is you don't know
what fans are going to do and when
during the Andor panel or at the end of
the panel they were quoting your
character's lines like as a group so
what is that like oh that's it was
amazing that when we when we were
leaving that pattern and they were
chanting one way out it was it was
mind-blowing it was a kind of it really
it sort of exemplifies what is so
extraordinary about the Star Wars
Universe the fans the storytelling and
the whole world of it because it's a
it's kind of like this cyclical kind of
you know when you think about the
original films and the series now how
the TV series are now driving you know
kind of younger audiences back to the
movies and it just feeds itself and it's
because because there's a there's a
coherent belief system that everyone
finds you know life enhancing and gives
them home
my last question for you I know you're
in the middle of directing animal farm
right now so what do you want to tease
people about the project in case they
don't know anything about it well well
you see you know it's a it's a it's a
it's a contemporary retelling of George
Orwell's fairy tale as as it's known and
is written in the books
um it's it's a it's a brilliant allegory
for and it's and a sadly kind of
eternally relevant book about absolute
power corrupting absolutely
um but there is also in our iteration of
it it's there is a lot of humor and and
the satire is is funny and it's a family
film it's it is meant for everybody so
so there is lots of layers to it and
there's humor for all ages and and and
and real faithfulness when did it come
out uh it'll be
shortly about this time next year okay
on that note I'm just going to say Sir
is a pleasure to talk with you always I
wish you nothing but the best